Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Agents of SHIELD we finally got to me Coulson’s
Cellist and there was a ton of awesome comic
book references.
If you’re not watching, now is a really
good time to catch up because there’s only
three more episodes left.
In case you missed it, I also announced I’m
not doing a bonus Marvel Movie video this
week just because I’m working on some special
bonus videos for Arrow.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So let’s talk some Agents of Playing Video
Games, who wouldn’t want to join that team.
Here’s my top 5 moments.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go, Number 5 - Coulson Tacks Down
Marcus Daniels
So many awesome things about about the infamous
list of meta-humans.
It’s really Skye that calls out the superpowers
aspect of the list.
Pretty much everyone in the Fridge has broken
out and they don’t really go too deep into
which super villains were in there, but Marcus
Daniels is the freak of the week.
In the comics he becomes Blackout.
I really appreciated that Coulson explained
the mechanism by which he gained powers.
What is it about the Marvel Universe and cosmic
radiation?
All I could think about was the Fantastic
Four.
It was a nice payoff to the Daniels arc that
Gamma Radiation based tech was the solution.
Also providing a nice opportunity for a Hulk
shout out.
The biggest question I had after Daniels explained
what happened to him in the Fridge was why?
Was it HYDRA scientists just conducting research
like Baron Von Strucker with Loki’s staff.
If you didn’t catch it at the end of Captain
America, HYDRA is experimenting with super
powers, but Von Strucker had Loki’s staff.
Which had the mind gem in it.
We can talk more about that in another video.
Number 4 - Patton Oswalt asks everyone what’s
in The Box?
Every time someone asks that question I always
get a Seven flashback.
I wonder if there’s an outtake with one
of the actors say “there’s a head, the
thing inside my mystery box is a human head”.
The chair itself just felt like the ultimate
SHIELD geek chair, which was basically who
Agent Koenig was.
He was like the ultimate Nick Fury fanboy.
Which actually brings up a really good question
let me know who you think is a bigger Nick
Fury fanboy, Agent Koenig or Agent Coulson?
My favorite part of the interrogation scene
was that Doctor Who shout out from Simmons.
Perfect answer.
Although I feel like a more honest answer
would have been “The Doctor”.
But if she had said that I feel like people
who don’t watch Doctor Who would have understood
what she meant.
But everyone understands what the TARDIS is.
Be sure to let me know in the comments what’s
in your box.
Number 3 - Ward makes his move on the hard
drive
I’m including him speechifying his backstory
in this.
It makes it a little easier to put the pieces
together on how he ended up with Garrett.
He said he rescued him from a bad situation.
And I think he was being honest about his
brother and his parents.
Garrett probably killed his parents and took
Ward into training.
I think the show will probably explain this
in greater detail once the rest of the team
figures out he’s HYDRA.
I was really bummed to see Patton Oswalt eat
it, but he will be avenged.
If you didn’t catch it, the reason he had
to take Skye and the Bus to Peru is because
the hard drive can only be unlocked at specific
locations.
Number 2 - May Quits Team Coulson and Tracks
Down Maria Hill
Kind of two big things, but really I don’t
think anyone thinks May actually quit the
team, she just needs some time.
But not only did we get to meet her mother,
who I’m guessing was a spy for the Chinese
Government or the Canadian Government or whoever.
But May is going to track down Maria Hill.
Marvel revealed she was coming back to the
show after Winter Soldier premiered.
So it’s not a big surprise.
We’ve know next week was going to be her
episode for a while.
I’m curious to see how she ends up helping
them, but as of right now.
She’s an employee at Stark Industries trying
to do something positive for humanity.
As opposed to invading everyone’s privacy
in the name of global security.
Either way, expect several awesome Tony Stark
jokes next week.
and my Number 1 moment - Amy Acker debuts
as The Cellist
The part was really short, but my favorite
Cellist moment was when she was explaining
how she met Coulson and their history together.
I actually expected him to reveal himself,
but we can debate whether or not he should
have in the comments.
If you never saw her on any of her other Joss
Whedon shows like Angel or Dollhouse.
She also starred in his movie Much Ado About
Nothing.
Which Clark Gregg was in.
That’s an amazing movie all by itself, it’s
like whedonverse heaven.
Seriously make sure you watch it.
They were kind of vague on it, but that speech
from Couslon at the end about telling her
when the time was right just leaves the door
open for Amy Acker to come back in the future.
If they do get a season 2.
She could always come back in a movie too.
But let me know what you’re favorite moment
was?
Seeing the supervillain Blackout or meeting
the Cellist?
For me it really was meeting that Cellist.
She was such a huge teaser in the first Avengers
movie that I’m surprised they didn’t make
the cameo bigger.
I guess we can pass that to tumblr to fill
in the gaps with fan fiction.
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, I loved
the A story, that Cellist Marcus Daniels story.
But I felt like the B story, Ward’s HYDRA
mission kind of pulled the episode down a
little.
I just don’t feel like Chloe Bennett was
able to pull off the double agent scenes.
I loved her and Ward before she discovered
his secret, but the way they edited the Patton
Oswalt reveal with the Cellist scenes didn’t
resonate with me.
I just don’t think it works when Skye is
acting.
Chloe Bennett acting ask Skye acting as secret
agent Skye trying to deceive Ward.
I’m not a big fan of characters acting like
other characters.
Unless it’s Tatiana Maslany on Orphan Black.
To be fair, the Cellist was such a huge pay
off.
It’s been like one of the long con’s of
the Marvel Universe, this person that’s
so important to Coulson, but that we’ve
never met.
And we’ve only been living with Patton Oswalt
for one week.
I was really sad he had to die though.
I’m hoping they eulogize him in some funny
way whenever they try to take down Ward and
Garrett.
Let me know what you’re final thoughts are
on the episode and do you think Coulson should
have revealed himself to the Cellist?
Like I said, because I’m starting special
Arrow bonus videos there’s no Marvel Movie
video this week.
I’m still going to do a couple Spider-Man
videos when that comes out in the United States
though.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Right now click here for that Arrow Bonus
video and click here for last week’s Agents
Of SHIELD.
Thanks so much for watching, see you guys
tomorrow.
High Fives!